you know who i think everybody would
love to hear you work with
would be someone like rod wave is that
somebody you would ever oh
i know rod wave seems to be like a very
emotional guy you know what i'm saying a
little erratic on twitter at times
but i feel like i feel like fans would
love to see y'all do some [ __ ]
yeah i feel like oh we i mean we used to
chop it up like you know
since he you know said blow that we
really chopped it up like that but like
you know bro used to be like you know
saying a real fan of mine like before he
even blow blowed up like
you could definitely hear it for sure
nah for sure like he used to be
like a real fan of mine so uh maybe one
day
yeah you know you know you know how it
is man you know really
but if you go back to his uh like he's
like his first video with the
heart on ice like that was gonna i first
like met him at this show
or he was over enough for me uh
and uh his cameraman was trying to get a
little dropped for he was doing like a
little promo video and he was like man
blue do a drop for my artist
then i know you know what's how i got on
the camera like you know i messed with
them done a lot
stuff like that so you know it's just
good to see you know what it's just good
to see like
artists just blow up i saw so many
artists blow up through
you know what i'm saying i just saw so
many artists blow up like artists that i
was
messing with tapping it earlier tapping
in early with it or just
blowing up you know saying some stay
silent some of them like
you know what i'm saying get on they you
know it's like i ain't never did nothing
bro
you know what i'm saying but yeah
sometimes if it'd be like sometimes
there'll be other people in there
like right oh y'all you know what i'm
saying y'all sound
saying you shouldn't you know saying
some people be feeling like
you know you know if y'all in the same
lane they really don't want to like
work you know yeah i think that's the
thing that i'd love to see
like like like you know like you said
like unfortunately like i remember when
he went online and said what he said
about other people singing and [ __ ] but
it's like yo just because
you you do this and we kind of are in
the same lane
they don't make us competition or you
know that's that weirdo [ __ ] i feel like
that should be happening a lot with
artists and it's like bro like
especially if it's people out the same
city you know what i'm saying obviously
he's from st
pete but like yeah you would just like
think like the
why not share each other's fans why not
you know collaborate you know what i'm
saying yeah he'd be good like
i like i like natural stuff though i
like of course i like natural stuff like
you know what i'm saying i never know
what's gonna happen in the in in the
future but you know i just like want to
work with everybody that want to
work with me you know i'm saying 100 man
you know well look
the album is coming soon yeah crazy
features
uh the song is on the radio go go
request that [ __ ]
and uh and check out the homie young
blue man just get it
boom